good afternoon stefan good afternoon
everybody
i'm pleased to announce today
investments from the eu innovation fund
worth 122 million euros for over 40
projects to bring low carbon
technologies to the market
in energy intensive industries in
hydrogen energy storage
and renewable energy the funding for
these investments is generated by the
auctioning of allowances
under the eu emissions trading system
the beneficiaries will receive either
grants
or project development assistance to
scale up their innovative projects and
bring them to the market as soon as
possible
the european investment bank provides
the project development assistance
the projects concerned by today's
announcements are located in 15
different eu member states plus iceland
and norway
deploying these technologies will help
the european union to achieve its
ambitious climate goals
you will find more information in our
press release and a map of the selected
projects
is also available online thank you
thank you very much tim thank you very
much tim unfortunately we also have
sad news we have learned of the passing
yesterday
of a former colleague of yours mr franco
papito
on behalf of the spokesperson service i
want to offer our sincere condolences
to his family and friends
franco started his journey as a
correspondent in brussels in the 1970s
and notably worked for la republica for
decades
he was an institution especially for his
italian colleagues in brussels
always guided by a pro-european spirit
and he was one of the founders of
european journalism
in the capital of the european union i'm
sure that he will be remembered
fondly by many of you and he remains in
the thoughts of the spokesperson
service with this the floor
is yours i will maybe first see whether
any questions in the room today
yes go ahead
hi um i wanted to know
um regarding the the
eu cert digital certificate
if you have noticed any problems
in the implementation by member states
especially
regarding non-resident eu citizens that
are
in another member state and that they
can they might have problems
uh getting this certificate uh in for
example in catalonia there has been some
problems regarding this
so i wanted to know if uh from the
european commission you have detected
these problems and if
you are trying to solve it in any way
thank you very much i think this would
be a question for adelbert
albert are you with with us i am with
you indeed
um so i i cannot tell you anything
specific about
uh issues in specific member states uh
as regards
this um this particular question but
maybe as a
as a general point i can um i can
definitely confirm that the
eu digital coverage certificates needs
to be issued
by the member state where the the
vaccination was administered
or where a test has been carried out or
whether recovered person is located
depending on the type of the certificate
regardless of whether they are
registered in the national systems or
not
and when a member state it might not be
in a position to offer
all functionalities to persons that are
not registered in the systems for
example
they might not be able to use the member
states application
they must at least be able to obtain a
an eu digital covered certificate
compliant paper
and pdf format certificate
and of course as always we welcome the
fact that several member states are
making efforts
to ensure this possibility which is
provided for in the eu digital covert
certificate regulation
thank you very much albert do we have
any further questions regarding the
digital certificates
only raise your hands if that is the
case
i don't see any hands in the room
but virginia
hello
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do we have any other questions on
vaccines
i see that moses has raised his hand
more so go ahead
yeah follow up excuse uh sorry moses i
will first
give the floor back to virginia virginia
follow up
[Music]
vaccinated
[Music]
delivery
um moza you had a question on vaccines
as well i think
it seems you have no microphone
that would be a bit difficult
no okay moza try again later maybe
or otherwise contact us bilaterally or
put your question in the in the
chat box we go now to get rip
and i humbly apologize for my awful
pronunciation
hi thank you for taking my question so i
wanted to ask
uh like now we reached 70 percent right
but i wonder
what's next is the commission already
thinking um
maybe by like maybe we should reach 80
or something
because delta variant is surging and 70
won't be enough and also taking into
account the vaccine hesitancy
it's an issue that cannot be tackled so
easily as deliverables
that happened with in the beginning of
vaccination um
so i wonder just what's next what are
the plans
thank you very much for this um what's
the next step well the next step is that
we have to ensure
70 percent of adult population that has
a double vaccination
emma has already stressed several times
that a double vaccination
is the best way to protect ourselves
against the virus but also against the
variants
so that work remains extremely crucial
extremely important and we're all
focused i would say on ensuring that
this target
can be met you are right that vaccine
hesitancy can in some cases be
an important obstacle this is something
we are definitely following up clearly
we
are helping member states as much as we
can with communication
and information campaigns helping
member states to show the importance
indeed in their communication to the
citizens of having double vaccination
on the basis of scientific elements
commissioner ki aquidas is as you know
making a tour of several member states
talking to the different member states
offering political support to reach this
target
to see how the commission can help
because as i said in the beginning
we are really focused now on achieving
double vaccination
of our adult population thank you
um christian
concerns
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
you also have a question on vaccine
system
we see you we see you
we don't hear you seeing is already nice
but hearing would be better
okay try again later
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
david
thanks stefan i wonder if you could tell
us
in light of how well the eu is doing
on vaccination rates if you think it is
justified for the united states to
maintain a travel ban
on european citizens also the state
department within 24 hours has issued
travel warnings against going to some
member states including spain portugal
and cyprus we know the eu is consulting
the commission was consulting quite
closely with the americans in
development of the uh of the
travel certificate the vaccine
certificate chose to be able to have
interoperability there
is there a gap somehow in communication
and again
the main question being is it justified
for them to re to keep these
prohibitions in place
um thank you very much david i will
immediately pass the floor to albert
regarding
the the decision of the united states in
this regard
the only thing i can say is i can only
repeat what i said last week as well
that um indeed we have noticed that not
all member states have reached the same
level of vaccination many member states
have made
very important progress this allows us
to say today for instance that 70
percent
of adult population has received at
least one dose
but we are not there yet and
in some member states further
vaccination will be extremely
important obviously but we continue to
follow this with the member states and
again
commission ki aquidas has met with
several member states to follow up on
the situation
maybe adelbert you would like to say
something on the us angle here
here sure absolutely very happy to give
you an update of the
of the state of play uh on on this issue
um we are in we're in close contact with
the us administration on the issue of
safe resumption of all travel
between the eu and the us as you know we
have received reassurances
that this is a high priority issue for
the us administration
we are engaging in good faith with the
us
discussions are ongoing at expert level
and we have an
adjoined eu s experts working group on
travel resumption
and we will continue engaging uh with
the uas on this issue
the last meeting of the group was on the
9th of july
and we are now waiting for the u.s side
to confirm a date for the next meeting
and our assessment remains that there is
a strong case
for the us to reopen to travelers from
europe and for the reasons that
stefan mentioned generally speaking as
you know the council has been
recommending that
all eu member states lift the
restriction on travel
for u.s residents regardless of the
vaccination status
since the 18th of june based on the
available scientific evidence
and without prejudice to any possible
health-related measures such as testing
or quarantine
where required by the eu member states
and reciprocity
in general is one of the elements that
member states have to take into account
when deciding on lifting travel
restrictions for a specific non-eu
country and
it is for the council then to consider
any such reciprocity issues
thank you albert i see david you have a
follow-up question
thanks stefan just quickly adam if you
could
presuming as you say that the uh eu has
been acting in good faith
would you say the same thing about your
american partners
and can you say specifically if the
united states officials were in touch
about the latest announcements was their
consultation and to whom
in the in the commission did they speak
within the last 24 to 36 hours before
this latest announcement or did they
speak to anyone
albert albert thank you
thanks david um i would have to check
with our experts what exactly contacts
uh have have taken place and also check
with the with that delegation in
washington
so if you allow me i would have to come
back to you on this
thank you very much maybe let's come
back to questions regarding the vaccines
um i see that tomaso you may have
managed
to find the right audio
yes can you hear me we hear you all
right thank you
okay uh thank you uh apologies for
people
for before it's just a question on the
pace of vaccination
because i've seen from the ecd
minister but we're much less
than which is i mean it is
understandable and i think it was
expected
by but i wonder if you have any
suggestion to member state
to speed up the pace of vaccination even
due
tomorrow we are losing we are losing you
so
the only uh question that i understood
was do we have any suggestions for
member states to speed up vaccination um
um unfortunately i did not understand
the first part of your of your question
you can you may wish to
put it in the in the chat or otherwise
uh text us
um anyway in terms of speeding up the
vaccination
it's a message that we pass to all the
member states that it's very important
that we have in short
deliver of a sufficient number of
vaccines it's now indeed up to member
states to
to administer the vaccines that they
receive as quickly as possible and as i
explained
the members the commission stands ready
to support um
as much as possible um
okay um acanta
go ahead on vaccines i guess the
vaccines i guess
no are you able to hear me i hear you
but
i hear you but okay so no sorry it was a
follow-up
to david's question so maybe it's more
for an albert okay
let's okay let's let's wait a moment and
we'll get back to that i'm sorry for
mixing up otherwise the the the two um
topics um oliver you have a question
yes yes hello on vaccines
uh or rather on the protection of fully
vaccinated
people against the virus the centers of
disease control
a couple of days several days ago
published um
an article by by several researchers in
its uh
emerging infectious diseases journal i'm
sorry this sounds a bit obscure but it's
i think of general interest about
breakthrough
infections of the gamma variants
in fully vaccinated gold miners in
french guyana
so there's there's a gold mine in french
guyana all the miners they are fully
vaccinated and still
the majority of them actually were
infected by this gamma variant
unfortunately none of them had serious
symptoms but i think about 80
of them were symptomatic so it's not
simply a matter of being infected but
they had symptoms so
these men were fully vaccinated and
still the majority of them got the
vaccine my first question is
is the commission aware of this case
and if uh you're aware of this case
of this case how i mean which
decisions should member states take
which you know
decisions in terms of vaccination policy
or uh
you know immigration rules or uh you
know non-pharmaceutical intervention and
so forth
do you consider necessary thank you um
thank you very much oliver the only
thing that i can say on this topic
is that of course we remain in close
contact with the colleagues of the ecdc
their job is to monitor
the situation of the of the vaccines and
of the vaccination
and all reports and studies and findings
that they establish are of course
extremely important
these studies findings uh are also
used in our discussions with the member
states for instance
in the context of the health security
committee where representatives of
member states commission
and agencies sit together to talk the
situation to
discuss the situation see what
challenges we are facing
but i cannot say anything in particular
on this uh
specific case but again we remain in
close contact with
ecdc thank you
nicola go ahead
i think i hope you can hear me now we
hear you yes absolutely
perfect thank you uh so i would like to
uh go back to
to the traveling uh and third country
certificates because i really like
sorry can i interrupt you one second i'm
really sorry nicola we'll get back to
you but
we'd like to keep the topics together i
would maybe just still raise
allow people to raise questions about
the vaccines first and then we go to the
travel all right
but i've written note and written down
your name nicola we'll get back to you
david did you have another question on
vaccines
no your hand is okay no questions on the
vaccines in the room
then i would suggest we close this topic
and indeed
we go to nicola sorry nicola but uh
you have the floor thank you
uh so i'd like to ask about the
certificates covet certificates and the
traveling
i will stick to serbia because serbia
vaccinated a lot of people
we got the certificates in serbia they
are compatible with the
eu system as we're told but citizens uh
still have the problem to
enter the many european countries
they're turned back at the borders
even if the uh a certificate from serbia
is accepted like
it was situation in greece so uh
how can people definitely get an eu
certificate i've heard otherwise
mentioning the paper one etc because
what is the difference between that one
and application
and basically what people should do to
avoid the single one to call the state
authorities because this is ridiculous
i mean just to ensure to that they can
enter any of the state within european
union
uh even if they go uh to the border
they risk to be turned back again so
what should they do and how can travel
be will be enabled for third country uh
nationals which are vaccinated
uh meantime i mean what can european
commission do to help it
um thank you very much nikola i'm very
happy to give the floor to my smart
colleague adelbert
adelberts
thank you very much i hope i can give a
smart uh answer
the uh the situation is as follows as
you know
uh it is possible uh according to the
council recommendation that is in place
for people who are fully vaccinated to
enter the eu for non-essential reasons
now when uh when it comes to proving
the vaccination status uh there are
essentially
two routes uh that that are possible one
is
the eu digital government certificate
and one is
a third country certificate now when
somebody
comes to the border with the third
country issued certificate
then the national authorities need to
need to look at
these this documentation and assess to
what extent
it is it is completely
acceptable to them to what extent it is
um verifiable credible
and corresponds to the to the national
rules and this is something that every
member state
will have to do separately so
when it comes to advice to travelers i
think the the only relevant uh
piece of advice i can give is to check
with the national national authorities
of the member state
where they will be entering entering the
eu when it comes to the eu digital
coverage certificate
again there are two possible routes to
obtain one
one is for uh for a traveler to ask
a member state to give them a an
eu digital covert certificate which a
member state can do on the basis of
um any proof of vaccination uh or test
or um or recovery that is brought by by
the person
however that again is at the discretion
of that member state
and finally there is the possibility to
have a
an equivalence decision whereby
the certificate issued by that country
is recognized within the eu as a whole
as
equivalent to an eu digital covert
certificate and that is
very much something that is done
at eu level and as you know
uh or you may know we have one
current one such decision in place
currently with switzerland
when it comes to other countries we are
very much open to working with our
partners
around the world and of course also that
includes our neighborhood
we have been approached by many
countries that are interested in
in the eu digital covert certificate and
we're very glad about this of course
we have a very clear process in place
where we share
the the general information the
technical information about the eu
system
with our partner countries via our
delegations in the countries
and once a country interested in joining
our system
checks the specifications and believes
that it is technically ready to join
it can then send an official request to
the european commission
and we follow that an open source
approach so we have reference
applications and software that is
published online to facilitate
implementation and rollout on
on the national level and we have um
we have a large number of these requests
coming from from many different
countries we're holding
explanatory meetings uh with with the
countries on on the requests
and uh this work this work progresses
it's a
it's technical work that uh that needs
to be completed before
any such equivalence decision can be
taken i hope that explains
in detail thank you very much albert for
this indeed
smart answer um i see no further
questions for adelbert are there any
questions here in the room for alberts
no
okay let's open for other topics now
do we have yes please
mercifully politics
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
m
yes hello i would like to ask about the
internal commission affairs if that's
okay
uh politico says that there is sorry to
interrupt you
we're in sorry to interrupt you we are
still in foreign affairs so we will uh
i will first take questions on foreign
affairs for
nabila we will get back to your question
noureddin you have a question for us on
foreign affairs
[Music]
the constitution
[Music]
david you had a question
thanks very much stefan uh thanks nabila
i wonder if if you could just
walk us through um you worded this quite
quite carefully but the high
representative issued this statement on
behalf of the eu
the extent to which member states or
perm reps were consulted about this
exactly who is who is speaking here
and and noting in the statement then
that the eu is recalling
its considerable support for tunisia can
you talk about
so at this point just to be clear on
what you're saying the eu is monitoring
watching but not doing anything and
would the assessment be then that the
considerable support
provided in the past was not enough to
help
preserve the the one democracy that
seemed to emerge
uh from the arab spring thanks
um i'm not sure i understood your
question david but what i can tell you
is that usually a declaration on behalf
of the hrvp
is a declaration by 27 member states
so this means that the declaration has
been consulted with the 27 member states
through the council working groups at
this point i can i don't know which one
of them
is was the one through which the
declaration was
was consulted with but this is how a
declaration usually
comes so it means that it is the hrvp
talks on behalf of the 27 member states
um i'm
not sure i answered your question or if
you have a follow-up question to that
yes david no yes go ahead well i'm i'm
happy to clarify nibila i guess that
this has come up in the context of other
situations in the maharab or in the
middle east
where the eu struggles to speak
on behalf of the eu and its member
states so we've seen statements for
example in the u.n security council
by the eu ambassador on behalf of the eu
but not
on behalf of the eu and its member
states
drawing a distinction so it leaves us
sort of questioning
who exactly is has endorsed and joined
in this statement i mean we also have a
situation where again i i
respect and understand that it's summer
so we see you know the statement says
you know on behalf of the high
representative but oftentimes we do hear
from the high representative himself
quoted and we know that it's his voice
his
words so i guess i was trying to
understand was this a statement that was
constructed
in brussels and the extent to which the
capitals were consulted involved
and had it been endorsed by the foreign
affairs council by the ministers or by
perm reps and then again moving past
that once once you can adjust
if you could you know as specifically as
you can who has issued this statement
then getting to the substance of it
where it recalls the considerable i
think is the word support
from the eu to tunisia is the assessment
and that this has come up
short this support because tunisia is
now in what appears to be a serious
crisis
of democracy and and the last piece
being is the eu
doing anything other than watching as we
all are
with great concern is there any you said
you spoke with the
with the foreign minister is there other
action happening on the ground by the eu
delegation or by anyone
in an effort to restore democratic
functioning in the country thank you
well um again uh
to answer your question it has the eu uh
the eu declaration that was published
this morning went through the whole
process which is the normal process that
we have where the hrvp
is speaking on behalf of the 27 member
states where all member states have been
um have been consulted through the
the the formal channels through which
they are
always consulted uh dha and you would
have noticed that
the publication was done also through
the council
so this is what i can say when it comes
to
what the eu is doing i mean you know
that the eu has a
a privileged partnership with with
tunisia
we have we are a strong partner of
tunisia
um having said that uh the
the situation is unfolding it's been 24
hours
what we're trying to do is we follow the
situation we are talking with our
counterpart and the hrvp
has spoken to the foreign minister
and consulting of course with
the member states um it is
key principles are here there is the
respect of the rule of law and democracy
and fundamental rights
as essential principles that must be
preserved
the stability of the country and the
proper functioning of the institutions
are the key democratic and the
resumption of normal institution
activities
are key for the eu and this is something
that
that we are reiterating as the eu
the hrvp also reiterated this
on behalf of the 27 member states
well that's what i can say i don't i'm
not sure i can add to this
thank you very much i think this is how
far we can go
lawrence norman did you have a question
on tunisia
lawrence are you with us
hello yeah i'm here can you hear me we
hear you go ahead we hear you guys
sorry apologies um yeah nabila sorry i
just just want to push a little bit
a little bit more on this i know you're
constrained on how far you can go
um is there any discussion there it's
hard to underestimate the importance of
uh of what's going on in tunisia and the
stakes for the eu
is there any discussion of bringing
foreign ministers in any form together
on this um at this point and secondly
just to go back
a little bit to the question nurdinence
asked i mean the important
line in the communique today was about
the immediate
re-establishment of parliament which is
of course what the president has
suspended
um is at some point
um at some point in the next few days we
will know
whether that is the parliament has been
reestablished
um and unfrozen in its activities within
the the quick uh within within um
[Music]
let me rephrase that we will know
whether the president has any intention
of bringing the parliament back
anytime soon if it becomes apparent that
the president
is not intending to bring parliament
back
any time soon um what consequences
does that have in terms of financial
aid or any kind of sanction or any kind
of activity
thank you thanks uh thanks again uh
lawrence um about bringing foreign
ministers
uh together they say i i don't have any
information uh going in this sense as
you see
uh there is a declaration on behalf of
the 27 member states who seem who are
very much in line on uh the the
the position of the eu regarding what
happened 24 hours ago in tunisia
i mean apart from that i mean i think
that
you know and you've been very old in
this press room um
not that you're an old person lawrence
but you you know very well that
i cannot speculate i cannot or today
answer
an if question as to if they do not go
back
what are we going to do i think it is
extremely premature
you know very well that things how
things happen
we are following the situation in
tunisia
we are discussing with the tunisians we
are discussing among member states
and if something needs to happen it will
happen but at this point in time there
is nothing i can tell you
in terms of what if the parliament
doesn't go back or the institutions are
not
back to to functioning normally
indeed thank you very much i think you
had a question
[Music]
um
is there anything you could add anna
okay
um hi so many thanks for the question um
indeed
as nabila has recalled um you know the
eu has been concentrating
on support for helping tunisia to
[Music]
to to address the coronavirus pandemic
and we have mobilized a total of 330
million euros
have been made available for tunisia
around 260 million have already been
spent
um so we have been stepping up indeed
our support in the in the health sector
um we have an ongoing programme that's
covering
support for public hospitals to purchase
medical supplies
and provide training and medical
assistance um we have also uh um
helped to buy equipment um and also
material for disinfecting
um and sanitizing our public spaces um
you know that um we have been also
making
uh payments uh for ongoing uh budget
support uh programs and these have been
increased and
we have been front loading uh uh to help
mobilize quickly funds
um and we've disbursed to date uh 240
million to help
tunisia bring liquidity for the for the
treasury
in order indeed to help them be able to
address
the covet-19 pandemic and you know that
we have also approved a new
600 million low interest loan
on macro financial assistance
and as regards you know our broader
support
you know that um our main funding
instrument
um until now of course has been the
european uh neighborhood
uh instrument and we have um mobilized
over 1.6 billion euros
since uh 2014 um uh in support of
tunisia and
um i think that you know as nabila has
already of course
explained uh very well um you know
amongst the eu
tunisia partnership priorities are of
course promoting good governance
and the rule of law and of course you
know
as we've said you know also investing of
course in a stimulate
um economic growth and generating
employment in particular of course
for the youth and i think that it is
very clear that um
going down the future um good governance
and respect for
the um human rights and the rule of law
will continue to be of course an
integral part of the relationship
between the eu and tunisia
thank you very much for this extensive
overview do we have any other questions
on tunisia
i don't see anything here nor in the
chat box
do we have any other questions on
foreign affairs
not in the room not in the
chat or okay very good
then we open the floor to any other new
topic that you may have
yes indeed lo kagalis and again my
apologies for the awful pronunciation of
your name
it's okay thank you very much for the
floor so uh
about the teleworking in the commission
politico says that
there is a discussion on teleworking in
the commission
and some are advocating that the
commission
employees must work remotely i think
from the automotive or from the from the
next year i don't know about that
for at least one day a week so
what's positive effects do you think the
decision would bring and what are the
prospects in general on mandatory
teleworking
in the commission thank you for your
answer and i will have a second question
after this thank you okay thank you very
much
thank you indeed for giving me the
opportunity to take stock
of vervia on this very important
topic i mean i'm afraid i'm going to
disappoint you because i'm not able to
give you any any figures
any ratios any proportions as to how
telework and
and what we call in french travel
will be organized from um the next month
on versus an ongoing reflection process
of course the past year has been a
challenging one um
about one and a half years ago the
commission of a sudden like many other
public administrations or any
uh private uh enterprises all of a
sudden had to move from
a normal way of working to a televerk
arrangement and of course the
experiences that have emerged
have been extremely positive and of
course
just like any other public
administrations around the world the
commission as well
is going to try to incorporate telework
into the working methods even in a post
covered era so
there have been reflections ongoing as
to the specific
number of days colleagues should spend
in the office and
could spend
at home there are no concrete figures
that i could communicate to you at this
point in time
but what is important is that there will
be a so-called human resources strategy
that the commission will come forward
with in the course of the autumn
probably around
october and this will be a document
which will basically
specify um more information in this
regard so for now we have to wait
but what i can um confirm of course is
that television will be part of the
of the package will embrace the level
who will give more importance to it um
than in the pre-covered era but it's not
period
what this uh exact proportion and
portion uh
will be thank you as you've heard um in
douglas we are working on
teleworking um mindaugas you have a
follow-up question on this
question on this yeah i don't have a
follow-up question but i have
another topic if that's okay let's wait
a second wait a second i see that oliver
raised his hand it may be on this issue
as well
is that the case oliver
no it's not any other questions um
telework human resources balash's wide
portfolio
all right then we will open the floor to
other topics
oliver go ahead
hi yeah i'm sorry my editors
worked me really hard in this final week
before i
finally get on vacation on frontex more
seriously
um the the french minister of interior
has asked frontex to help
with uh surveying um
the channel coast given the uh
repeated numbers of people trying to
cross the channel from france to
um our recent former
member states and i was wondering if the
commission is worried about frantics
getting a bit overstretched i mean we
see them now uh being
requested to work on the lithuanian
belo russian border there might be
problems on the
polish russian border you never know
what lukashenko has in mind we now have
this request from france and so forth
and so forth and so forth
are you confident that frontex is is you
know
properly equipped and managed to deal
with these very very different
and and difficult tasks and in general
what you do about the
the french request to you know
be active there on the channel cost
thank you
thank you very much oliver i'll have to
bring in adelbert again adelbert
alberts thank you very much
um so first maybe maybe about the the
specific
uh issue of frontex presence at the
french
uk border on that
any such request for support need to be
first discussed
bilaterally between frontex and the
requesting and the requesting member
states
and this is not something where the
commission has specifically a role
it's going to be for the agency to uh
to look into how to satisfy uh such
such requests uh this said we are of
course in contact in constant contact
with
both france and frontex and we will
discuss any such
such requests with both parties in in
due time
now when it comes to the resources of
frontex more generally
uh you are right that the mandate of the
agency
is is very broad it covers all of the
external borders of the eu and if you
look at the
um the european border and coast guard
regulation which is
uh um which is the mandate of
uh of the agency um it specifies a very
very broad
range of tasks and of course uh also
it refers to very considerable means
that uh frontex
needs to have it is uh going to be by
far
the the largest eu agency by budget
it um the the frontex budget will
continue
increasing in the in the current mff and
it is something that the commission has
uh very much supported and has worked
with the co-legislators
um and with the member states to make
sure that that this is the case
and of course the objective remains for
frontex to have 10 000
um members of the standing core of the
european border and coast guard
in order to be able to um to really have
a very very substantial
presence uh at the european borders this
said
um it is also the case that uh frontex
needs to
needs to rely on uh the ability of
member states
to supply um uh personnel and and means
in case of request for support
and of course uh that that remains a
shared responsibility uh of all of all
of the member states of the eu
that's uh these are the the general
elements that can provide
to you but of course if you have more
specific questions about a particular
request or support
you know that frontex has a press office
which
is i am sure would be very pleased to to
reply to specific questions
thank you very much albert um i see here
that several hands are raised please
only keep your hands raised if you have
questions on
frontex only keep your
uh there
yes oliver you have a follow-up
yes thank you thank you for the answer
but a political question that's why i'm
asking you is the commission not the
frontex
press office if you look at what the
french minister of interior is asking
for
i'm a bit perplexed because he's asking
for drones for
um uh you know night
how do you call them night sight goggles
and uh and these cameras that actually
how do you call thermal cameras or
whatever france is one of the most
developed member states in europe it is
it has
i think a very well developed border
force and i would be very surprised not
to find
plenty of these pieces of equipment in
the french
border force themselves so my question
to you is
do you think that member states like
france ask for the support of frontiers
because they actually really have a
need of drones and these things
or do you rather think they do this for
political reasons in order to
draw the attention of the rest of europe
to their very specific border and
migration problems
by which i mean is if there's people
crossing the channel
it's kind of a french british problem
but if the french say well frontex has
to come look now frontix has to be
active here
they can say well this is a european
problem and thereby they can
increase the pressure on maybe countries
like greece
or italy where these migrants might have
might have entered the eu in the first
place so you get my point do you are you
worried that frontex somehow becomes
sort of a political
a gimmick or a political punching ball
thank you thank you very much oliver i
don't think it's
up to us to um speculate why member
states ask what they ask
which needs they have which reasons they
have to ask
whatever it is they ask but maybe albert
would like to
jump in here
thanks a lot stefan and thanks oliver
because this also allows me a little bit
to clarify
the overall framework in which the
border management in the eu takes place
as stefan said i will not be able to
comment on the specific
uh uh request for support this is
something that needs to be discussed
between
uh between the agency and france in in
the first instance but
um if you look at the european border
and coast guard uh regulation
it uh it describes a system of european
border management
um which is a shared responsibility
of uh the of the member states of the
national authorities
and uh of the european border
coastal agency so frontex so the idea of
frontex is not that it is only an agency
that is present
uh specifically at uh at the
sections of the external border where
there is a
particularly acute need but it is an
agency that is supposed to
support member states overall in the
implementation of integrated
border management of course it is member
states retain the primary responsibility
for
the sections of the eu external border
however
overall it is it is a shared
responsibility and the agency
is is there to provide technical and
operational assistance
in the implementation of all uh of all
these measures
uh wherever and and and wherever needed
and that is also why uh the uh the size
of the
um standing core of the european border
and coast guard
is um is going to be so significant uh
once it is
fully in place so um i
i think the um there is um
there is no particular uh concern that
uh that frontex should only be requested
to
uh to help at in in particularly acute
situations
thank you uh alberto that was very clear
lawrence
you have a question for albert on
frontex as well
yeah just just very quickly there was a
lithuanian readout on the
on bond alliance conversation with uh
with the lithuanian pm
last night on the situation with belarus
anything to add from your side
any um any promises of
extra assistance or anything from the
presidents to the lithuanians
thank you maybe what i could say is that
um indeed
the president of the lithuanian prime
minister had a very constructive
phone call regarding the arrival of iraq
and northern african migrants
into lithuania the prime minister
briefed the president on the current
state of play and the president offered
her support
she asked high representative borel and
the commissioner johansson
to follow up on these matters including
with their iraqi counterparts
especially with regard to the
readmission of migrants
and increasing air traffic which is a
cause of concern
the president also offered to stay in
touch with the prime minister to follow
the situation
as it evolves um
nomi you also have a question for um
albert on frontex
thanks my question was answered thank
you so much perfect naomi
christian question for adelbergs
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
um
um
[Music]
um
no sorry my question is for vela so i
can just wait
okay thank you um
go ahead
yes hello one more time i have a
question about lithuania
and belarus a austrian interior minister
criticized the eu saying that it is
sending a wrong message to lithuania
because it only funds
migrant camps and gives money for for
the accommodation of migrants
and won't help with some sort of
physical barriers on the border or just
simply a wall
so what is the european commission
position on
a physical barrier on this particular
wall with lithuania and belarus do you
think it is needed
and the other question about the iraq
because
most of the of the migrants who are
going to between
are from iraq is so um
and lithuanian foreign minister spoke
and visited iraq and spoke to the
iraqi fm like a week ago i think
and the result of that was even more
flights to belarus and
that means more migrants to lithuania so
could the european union do something
with i don't know iraqi
airlines or or planes going to belarus
thank you very much thank you
um adelbert
could you come in here could you come in
here
sure so point by point uh
starting with the the issue of the of
the barrier along the border with
belarus
generally speaking the commission
supports border management in lithuania
and that's both operationally and
financially and we're also ready to
deploy
further assistance as required and in
fact we are in discussion with lithuania
about such further support
now we do not finance fences
but our funding supports integrated
border management solutions
that ensure that irregular border
crossings do not go undetected
and that then link to effective and fast
uh migration management
and and asylum systems now for more
details about the
the idea of a barrier that's um more
something i think
to ask the uh the lithuanian authorities
generally speaking coming to a second
point
the the eu provides different sorts of
assistance
to lithuania and this
corresponds to all the aspects of
migration management where we have
capabilities and we well we have
uh received requests from lithuania so
just to give you a couple of examples
um we have of course a number of
frontex officers that are currently
deployed
in lithuania and more uh are on the way
we currently have i believe
35 offices as well as
a certain number of assets europol is
also deploying guest offices in order to
look at
any potential security issues that need
to be tackled
and of course the european asylum
support office is also
helping lithuania there are two experts
currently
deployed and more are being being
provisioned
in addition there is uh a
in preparation a request for emergency
financial assistance
um for um for
approximately 10 to 12 million euro so
that's also something that that we are
discussing with
um with lithuania and of course as you
will have seen the union civil
protection mechanism has also been
uh been activated so this is all in
addition
to um efforts that are more on the
external affairs or diplomatic side
and uh on the specific question of uh of
contact with iraq i would just refer to
you to what
uh stefan just explained uh in the about
the phone call that took place between
uh president thunderline and the
lithuanian prime minister
thanks indeed thank you very much albert
and also add that
the civil protection mechanism of the
european union has also provided support
to lithuania 12 member states
participating
already last week giving through tenants
and so on and indeed um during the phone
call yesterday um
of the president um she agreed to ask
the uh vice high representative boyle to
follow up on these matters with
his iraqi counterparts in the area of
air traffic for instance which remains
in an area of concern
i have nuredin
you also have a question for us
ah sorry we have i'm sorry innovating
first we go back
there's a follow-up yes thank you very
much
just a little bit of context which i
well i know you know this context but
but
just to clear it out uh the lithuania
belarus border is not only the european
union border
it's also schengen area border and nato
border
so uh what the commission think isn't
that a shame that
the lithuania latvia estonia
poland don't have any physical barrier
with
with countries which are led by well
sometimes some some experts say uh the
dictators who are on
unpredictable so and you're saying at
the same time that the
european union couldn't help with the
with the wall so
um but maybe it should maybe maybe you
should
like help us build some some sort of
physical barrier thank you
thank you i'm not sure we can add
anything to that but maybe adelberry
would like to come in
i think that's correct i don't think i i
can i can add very much
um the european funds uh can finance
what is provided for in
in the law so in the in the specific
instruments that establish the different
european funds which is something that
is
determined by the european parliament
and the council
but broadly speaking you
you will certainly know that we have a
policy on integrated border management
where we cooperate very closely with the
member states
as to how exactly the internal
the external borders are to be managed
and there especially frontex has
a very very uh very very important role
and i am sure that
the authorities of uh lithuania as well
as all
other member states remain in very close
dialogue with uh with frontex as to how
how best to do it and there is in fact
a process called vulnerability
assessment
which structures this these discussions
and
and this cooperation so it is not
something that
is not at all managed on the european
level it is
on the contrary there is a process in
place that um
that makes makes it possible for all of
us to cooperate very closely on this
thank you very much albert i saw that
nouridhin had posted the question the
chatbox but
nabila has already replied to that
norwegian do you have still a question
for us then or
[Music]
stephen
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
um
[Music]
africa
tamar
thank you very much can you hear me yes
we hear you go ahead
great thanks my question is for vel and
it's relates to the polish uh register
sorry
i'm going to interrupt you a second i'm
sorry we're still with the uh with uh
albert but we'll get back to you
um sorry for that um oliver did you have
a question
on um frontex or migration or what
was just discussing um hi yes and
sorry again for coming again for the
fourth time today um
is is belarus a safe third country
uh in asylum law terms uh
in the view of the commission and
if so what merit would there be an
asylum claim
on the youth soil by an iraqi who enters
the eu
uh irregularly through belarus
thank you thank you
albert is your day i think it's your day
i think
thanks thanks a lot welcome back oliver
the uh
there is no provision in eu law
currently
and that would allow the commission to
or
give the commission the responsibility
to assess whether a specific country is
a safe
third country this is a this is
something an assessment that needs to
be uh done by the member states in
accordance with the asylum procedures
directive
and in fact it's an optional uh
procedural device for member states they
they are not obliged to
to use it so um i would suggest maybe
that you have a
have a look at the asylum procedures
directive and the specific criteria that
that are mentioned there however the
[Music]
each assessment needs to be needs to be
taken by the member states in fact
it also uh needs to take into account
the individual dimension
in case this this concept is applied
now when it when it comes to the merits
of
an assignment claim i will have to give
you the same same answer the the
the very principle of asylum law is that
every application is assessed
individually and
it needs to and the the national
authorities national determining
authorities
need to look at the detail of of every
claim
um separately in order to see who
qualifies for protection
and and who doesn't so i would not be
able to
make any such determination and even
more so not in in the abstract
thanks thank you very much albert i
don't see any further questions for
adelbert
um so let's open the floor to other
questions i think paola you had a
question
on the recovery plan is that correct
absolutely thanks um my question is for
villa and it relates to polish hungarian
recovery plan the assessment period
which has already been extended
according to my
calculations ends on the 3rd of august
could you please confirm that
and can the commission and the country
agree on a further extension
second um the vice president
dombrowski's yesterday said that
we might still need more time for the
polish plan for the assessment could you
give us some more information on why and
what
is the commission uh still struggling
with on the polish plan thanks
thank you very much thank you paula for
your
question so there were three of them
i'll start with your first question
so indeed you are correct um
the poland we have agreed with with
poland an extension
of the original two-month assessment
period
um and that brings us to the the first
of august
um the second question you had
was whether any further extension uh
to the first extension uh would be
feasible and i can also refer here to
what um executive vice president
dombrowskis has said
yesterday and indeed he was very firm
saying that it is not excluded that we
may
require still more time
but that we are not proposing a formal
further
extension at this stage um
but to to come back to the question
whether it's it's feasible
to prolong the extension for a second
time
there i can confirm that
this is possible under the regulation so
more in particular under article 19 of
the
rf regulation and so more generally
why uh why do we need um
more time well while we cannot assess uh
on on the exact uh issues that that we
are still clarifying
with poland as our assessment is still
ongoing
i think we explained very clearly last
friday
myself and and dana uh the importance
and the reasons uh behind the need for
such
a for any extension for that matter
and that is really to to clarify any
remaining issues to ensure that we
receive
as a commission all the information that
we need
to complete our assessment against the
11 assessment criteria under the
recovery and resilience facility
thank you very much um
do we have any other questions for
varela on this topic
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
um
mercy
[Music]
mom jill
yes it is and it's also related to the
recovering resilience plan but um
about the bulgaria's plan uh
we know that the bulgarian and
netherlands are the the
the only two countries that still have
to submit
their recovery and resilience plan but
bulgaria has submitted
its draft draft plan so has the
european commission any comment or
assessment of the draft until this
moment
thank you for your question so as you
rightly pointed out
bulgaria has not submitted a final plan
to the commission yet which triggers the
two-month uh
assessment period um by the commission
uh and uh but uh obviously we are we are
continuing to engage and to work
constructively
with the bulgarian authorities
and unfortunately while the assessment
is still ongoing we cannot
comment on any of the pending issues
of the assessment of the bulgarian plan
which is still
in draft format as i said
thank you christian spielmann
sepulveda
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
please raise your hands no not in the
room
do you have any other questions today
not in the room not in the chat box
then thank you very much stay healthy
and maybe another piece of good news
that i can give you is that the next
press midday briefing will be chaired by
ariana
see you later bye